hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer
and i provide content for new and
inspiring engineers
and today we're going to be talking
about the different ways you can get
into software engineering by going you
know to college and getting a computer
science degree
versus going to a coding boot camp
versus self teaching we're going to be
talking about the difference
in those three routes and so let's get
into it so let's start off with
getting a college degree this is
something that
most people would recognize as like the
traditional way to go into software
engineering getting a computer science
degree
however lately within you know the last
couple of years
there has been some debate as to the
best way to go
into the field with a college degree
there are many many pros to this one
especially if you're you know 18 to 22
years old you can get that college
experience
but specifically when we are talking
about
learning what you need to know for
software engineering it
provides you extensive knowledge of
you know computer programming and
algorithms and things
like that you also through going to a
college you also
get a lot of exposure to companies
like google like twitter because of
recruitment efforts that
they make efforts that the college
itself makes
and things like that on top of that if
you want to work for big companies like
google like twitter
it should be noted that with college and
being able to learn algorithms
so extensively it could set you on um
a better path to work for a company like
that
you in my opinion i i don't know
in my opinion you have a better chance
of getting a job right after college to
a place like
google rather than getting um a job
right away after self-teaching or coding
boot camp
at a place like google because you would
have gotten the extensive knowledge and
algorithms which is very very important
as google is a search engine and those
types of things matter time complexity
matters space
complexity matters so those are things
to
think about however when it comes to a
specialized
knowledge college is not really the
place you do that yes you get extensive
knowledge
in you know computer programming but you
also get extensive knowledge in you know
whether an atmosphere and in human
biology
and in you know social you know
justice classes and things like that and
so it sometimes you know depending on
what your goals are
sometimes it's not the right path
because i'm trying to you know if you're
trying to be a front-end engineer
and why am i over here taking science
and you know dissecting frogs and
everything like why am i wasting my time
doing that when i should be
learning languages and frameworks also
in terms of you know front-end
engineering college or most
colleges most traditional colleges don't
teach the modern languages
they don't teach you know frameworks
like react and bootstrap you
tend to learn more um of the like
older languages java um
c sharp c plus plus things like that
and so that's something to note like if
you
know you're trying to be a you know
front-end engineer
and do you have a real interest in ux
and ui design and
you want to be very competitive right
away and get what you're paying for
college may not be the right place for
that what might be the right place for
that going into
our my next section is a coding bootcamp
coding bootcamp provides a very
specialized knowledge me
i am a coding bootcamp grad i received
a college education but i received my
degree in
finance so to become a software engineer
and
to you know get through that transition
i went through a coding bootcamp
specifically
a full stack software engineer program
and so with that it was very very
specialized what we were learning we
were learning a back-end
technology a back-end framework to match
a front-end technology a front-end
framework to match
put those together we got full stack so
that is the route
i decided to take so one great benefit
is that specialization and because you
are so specialized
you can get through that process in just
a matter of months three to four to six
months
to up to a year rather than college
riches
four years of learning not but not only
computer science but
all of these different electives and
add-ons and so because with a coding
bootcamp you spend you know so much time
learning just one thing you get through
it faster
now coding bootcamp is expensive
college is expensive too but when you
look at
what you are getting out of college
versus what you're getting out of a
coding bootcamp in terms of just
curriculum and experience coding
bootcamp
is more expensive you know 10 to 20
000 dollars so literally yeah tens of
thousands of dollars
for three months four months six months
a year
and so you have to think
is it worth it is it worth getting into
that debt with college
it is you know a lot of money you know
up to hundreds of thousands of dollars
at the end of the four years
but there's robust structures for
scholarships
and financial aid and you get things
that you can't get with the coding boot
camp
like a one college experience something
that may be important to you
and two opportunities to learn different
things
which for some people they want to be
dissecting frogs you know when
in between coding classes like that's
something they want to do that's not
something that is a deterrent and so
looking at the cost of coding boot camp
just
in itself for the months you're getting
it is so expensive especially because
there are very limited
ways of um getting through that cost
really your only ways for payment are is
a loan
or cash some offer scholarships
i was lucky enough to get um a
scholarship but that only
covered a pretty small portion
of the entire cost and so that
is something that you really have to sit
down with your accountant and think
about and on top of that with coding
boot camps or at least most ones i
didn't
you don't learn algorithms and this is
something
that is not always needed
not always like specifically necessary
for
you specifically in the type of position
you want
but it's often very necessary during
interviews
and so what ended up happening was i had
to kind of like
take this crash course you know myself
in
algorithms and things like that and
practice constantly
after the coding boot camp was over and
really learned this
to make sure that during interviews when
i would be asked these things i
looked you know the part i looked like i
could
be the person for the job and so it is
unfortunate that
you know sometimes it requires the work
outside of the coding bootcamp even
though you just paid tens of thousands
of dollars
for this boot camp but then to be
specifically hired
not even to do the job like the job can
have nothing to do with alcohol
algorithms specifically but to just to
be hired or to be seen as hireable
you need to learn algorithms and so now
you pay
tens of thousands of dollars for x y and
z but you can't even get to this end
point without learning
this middle point of algorithms and so
now you're doing that all on your own
and so that is something that is very
disappointing but you can also
be one of the lucky ones who doesn't get
a technical interview portion
of their you know interview and the
company they're looking for
really cares about who you are as a
person how teachable and how moldable
you
are which i wish all companies did
i wish all companies did that because
you know what i can learn
you know all these different if
statements and algorithms
and you know o of n squared but you
can't teach me to be a nice person you
can't teach me to be driven
and you know prepared and all of these
things necessary
to be truly successful but there's my
you know there's my ted talk for the day
but yes in summary for coding boot camps
it is a much more specialized route for
you to go to
it's because of this you know
specialization it's much faster to
become a software engineer
through this route but it's also
extremely expensive
and you don't get to learn algorithms
so now we have self-taught before i talk
about
you know self-taught i just want to make
note that the way i see things if you're
a software engineer
you're self-taught every software
engineer no matter
if you went to school for this if you
went to a boot camp for this
you are self-taught because your college
you know you didn't teach your
javascript and so now you're in there in
your dorm room learning javascript
your bootcamp you know didn't teach you
this framework and that framework they
taught you true frameworks and so now
you're over here
preparing for this new job you have
learning view
and now just keep that in mind
no matter which route you end up going
to
there's a level of self-teaching that
goes into it
but for matters of this video when i say
self-teaching i mean you didn't
do anything else you didn't go to a boot
camp you don't go to
any program at all you don't go to
school or anything you are
in your room studying it up by yourself
so with self teaching one of the biggest
pros of self teaching
is the cost or the lack thereof
it is really the cheapest option because
you can buy
just books of udemy courses for you know
ten dollars a pop you know if it's if
there's a sale i mean i
i come in at the sales but just books of
ruby
and javascript and react and bootstrap
and all these things that are coding
bootcamp would teach you
a college would teach you and create a
curriculum for yourself
you can also get to resources like free
code camp free code camp
has um a fantastic youtube channel
where you get hours
hours of material
in just one video you get to build full
applications full features
in just one video five hours each
that is something that um has
become more common you know lately with
you know the rise of you know
youtube and search engines and things
like that people creating material
for the general public that is either
free or very low cost and so free code
camp isn't the only
you know people to do this if you just
you know google
how to you know create a website boom
there
is a tutorial for you shameless plug but
you can really learn a lot from just
looking at the resources
around you and a lot of them free so
that is one of the biggest benefits of
self-teaching there's also a great
community for people who are looking to
go into engineering through
self-teaching that is something that
i think um people don't really like
realize is very can be very crucial to
one's success the community
that they're in especially with
engineering the engineering community
specifically like people learning
how to be an engineer and learning how
to code it
is a very amazing community that can
really lift you up in your darkest days
and get you through that finish line
whether or not you know yourself
teaching or going through some program
it is something that can be very very
helpful
and so for self-teaching you still have
that community with you
so if you're looking for you know people
to you know hold you up and things like
that don't think you need to go to a
program to do that you can still
have that with self-teaching now where
the difficulty in self-teaching
comes and this is this was my difficulty
and what led me to go to a coding boot
camp
is now no one's really holding you
accountable
for your um progress for your
learning it's all you and so you need to
be
the one to remind yourself every single
day while you're doing what you're doing
and make sure you're taking those five
hours six hours eight hours
every single day every other day to
learn your craft and perfect it
that is something that is very hard to
do for some people
for me it's very hard to do i need to be
held accountable by a third party
specifically by someone who has
authority over me
and i need to be held accountable
by also something other than
just a person like for example money
i paid for this like you best believe
i'm getting through this
you know they said no refunds at the
door like i am getting through this
and so because of that you know fact
that i already opened my wallet to this
i know i'm getting through this where
self teaching doesn't have that
um associated risk i'd say to it where
it's like you paid for this or
this person is you know telling you you
have an assignment due or things like
that
that's where self teaching can be hard
where self teaching can also be hard is
you don't really have a road map
you don't have a teacher saying this is
the best way to
you know become a full stack developer
starting here then going down to here
then going here and then ending here
you don't really get that you have to
really kind of look at the community and
the resources around you and do your
research
to create that curriculum but it can be
done once you find out you know
that curriculum then you you know
purchase your udemy
you know purchase your codecademy
courses go on go
on free code camp and look at the
necessary things
but that specifically i'd say is one of
the hardest things lastly
another you know thing that can be
difficult to overcome
is having questions you watch this
youtube video you know for five
hours but you misunderstood something a
teacher said
or you did not understand why the
teacher chose
this function versus this function you
can't really raise your hand
you know you can't really you know go to
udemy and
i mean you can they have those comments
sections but like
i don't know i like a teacher
saying naya this is why i chose x
y and z and giving me a full rundown and
me being able to ask follow-ups on top
of it instead of me waiting
a day two days three days and now my
whole learning schedule is out of whack
because i never got through that one
question i had
so that's something that can be
difficult but then again
that's where the magical gift of google
comes in put in that question in google
put in that question in youtube just get
a different video you know to explain
you
to explain to you why they chose x
function versus x so yeah to sum up the
self teaching
it is extremely cheap the really the
cheapest option
two you have a great community to you
know
keep you accountable and keep you
motivated
however sometimes it takes more than a
community to keep you motivated it takes
you know
actual risk like money to keep you
motivated
and you don't get the you know
one-to-one instruction where a teacher
can
specifically guide you and you know
answer your questions and make sure that
you
are on the right path and so those are
you know just you know more things to
think about if you are trying to
pick between the three right now overall
i would think about what your end goal
is
if you can figure out that end goal
then you can have a better understanding
of which
route to take there we go everybody if i
you know help shed some knowledge on
anything for you today
please hit that subscribe button and i
will see
y'all soon so bye y'all